[Music]
the scene is a classic pub
in a
dodgy side of of
of london shall we say and our
mild-mannered sweet man sort of the
colin firth harry hart character is uh
having a a a sort of a lecture giving a
lecture to exit how
he could be doing better in life
and uh and eggs he says was all right
for you to say that with the aura born
with your silver spoon
[Music]
i don't know how many it was five or six
people then come in and uh
who have a beef with eggsy and they were
gonna beat the living crap out of eggsy
and they asked granddad to leave
granddad is very polite lee gets to
leave
tells him that there's a thing in life
called manners maketh man
are we going to stand around here all
day
or are we going to fight
[Music]
locks the pub door much to their uh to
their surprise
and then goes and beats the living [ __ ]
out of all of them with a sort of an
aplomb and style
unaccustomed to a colin firth style
english gentleman wearing a suit only
armed with an umbrella
[Music]
my secret weapon or not so secret weapon
was a man my second unit directs called
brad allen brad and i were extremely
close and worked
we were we were both just we both love
action and he was trained by jackie chan
and
he you know with him we would do stunt
visits where
we do every shot on a video camera with
you know with the pub we build it out of
cardboard boxes the stools the weapons
and then we do it again with the actors
and they learn it all so
when we're filming it's it's it's all
you don't make that stuff up on the day
let's put it that way i always say
action tell a story tell a story tell a
story with every shot so that's number
one
number two geography because i always
feel i don't know what it is about a lot
of action sequences
i always say the best
you know for me the best example of an
action sequence is all the boxing and
rocky because you know where they are
who's finding who what character you
like and where you are in the in in the
ring in the story in the round when if
they're down they're on the floor if
they're up they're up um so
that's
that's all that's an action sequence so
whether you go bigger or smaller it
doesn't matter if you tell
the story of the action and the story of
the movie and the characters and you
have geography shots
then it's enjoyable to watch instead of
just sometimes watching his action
sequences where you have no idea who's
hitting who where they are why they're
doing it and ultimately you guys don't
even care who wins
[Music]
not
available
[Music]
you know i love jackie chan
and i was trying to bring you know with
brad something like all that that style
of action combined with the british
etiquette and yet and british style and
and
that's how the sort of the kingsman
action
genre of what it is for that time by the
way is already changing but for that
moment that's what we came up with
[Music]
[Music]
we're such cheap low budget filmmaking
that we uh found out that the pub from
the world's end was about to be burnt
you know that set so i booked we just
bought that set and just
changed the wallpaper welcome to
independent filmmaking so no we didn't
we yeah we uh
borrowed a set should we say
[Music]
for me the most memorable thing is
watching colin firth train and doing it
and
when we cast colin
it was
he didn't know you know he really didn't
know i was like colin firth you know the
only action he'd done was that sort of
i don't even know the polite way of
saying it but let's say uh handbags at
dawn between him and hugh grant and
bridget jones so wasn't exactly uh it
wasn't the action hero but i even
remember taran saying because you know
he had to play you know he i said taran
your job is to be the audience i need
you to watch this and go oh my god
what's happening and we can cut you and
your jaws hitting the ground and i want
the audience to hopefully be feeling the
same way and i remember at the end of it
taran said i didn't have to act man i
was watching colin firth kick people's
asses in a very convincing manner he was
just shocked
[Music]
this is obviously in the sequel
and we wanted to rift on the fact that
you know
harry hart is back
and
that his memory isn't quite there so he
thought it'd be fun put him into like
the american equivalent of a you know a
pub
some
well how do i describe it a bit of a
divy bar
well pick them up
and that is not what i call a kentucky
welcome
manners
maketh man
let's say some uh
renegade guys not good guys come over
they're a bit abusive
and rude and trying to pick a fight and
we we're thinking harry has memories of
this sort of behavior so he gets up and
he goes to leave and he says man is
maketh man
and then the fun of it is when you think
okay he's going to kick everyone's asses
these guys just beat the living crap out
of him every nothing works he can't
remember it he is not the harry hart we
know which then
the fun of it was then to bring in the
statesman and say okay let's redo the
the pub fight in an american bar fight
style and we'll give him a whip
a lasso
let me translate that for you
as a kid i grew up on bar room brawls
whether it was the cannibal run or
john wayne and all these you know it was
so in my ironically
the inspiration for the bar you know for
the pub was the old westerns and the you
know if you think about the first scene
it's a very westerny you know thing two
guys having an argument one getting up
walking to the door but this time we
haven't got those saloon doors for you
know any
you know i was imagining imagining the
saloon door in a you know west and they
locked it instead of left out there was
all that and we tried to shoot it as a
western so here we're now in the
american
the we back we're in the bar which was
sort of the inspiration to the pub so
it's a little bit of the two things
riffing off each other and it was
pedro's first action sequence when he
was sort of
he went off and learned how to
how to fight with a whip and he did a
very good job
[Music]
he was showing me how he did it
and he did one flick and it caught his
hand and just drew blood immediately i
was i was
i was pretty impressed with him he um
yeah he went out and he learned how to
do it because it's
it's and it's harder to do when you're
in a room because you've got to be
really concerned you know
it's when you're inside you don't want
it to catch the wrong thing but he went
in he he learned it all he was really
good
what's wrong with me man i thought you
fixed me well we rebuilt your neural
pathways but it'll take time to get your
coordination back
[Music]
pushing the boundaries we tried to do
that quite a lot some people didn't like
that but we did think the sequel let's
push some of these boundaries and have
because something you know sometimes you
want to push it so far that you're not
remembering what you liked about the
first one so actually weirdly with the
last so we pushed that further and the
whip when we showed it was electrified
but we let we kept that for later on
when he's in the uh
spinning rig and that's when and um
and that's so so
you know we had we had to we couldn't go
too far in the bar sequence because we
wanted some more surprises with american
weaponry
[Music]
phantom butterflies you will experience
episodes lapses of clarity you'll be
back to normal soon
[Music]
[Music]
when we really looked into the sort of
the southern
gentleman and you know don't you know
mind your manners and there was a whole
big thing about manners in the south
which i thought was interesting the idea
of uh
louisville and kentucky and bourbon
versus british whiskey uh and just
saying how
you could have these two very similar
aims to say of a secret agency but they
couldn't be more different you know
channing and taran are very different or
jeff bridges and colin firth or jeff
bridges and michael kane that excited me
more and so so you know expanding into
the american culture which i grew up on
i love american culture in the pop
culture of america i'm 70s 80s boy so it
was all these
these elements which i want i'd love to
explore more but getting them into
kingsman was fun but also what i
realized when we were riding the golden
circle that what you know what really is
kingsman especially the modern kingsman
it's eggsy and harry it is that
relationship that people love the most
and writing it without colin didn't or
without harry didn't feel right to me
and that's why we we decided to bring
him back and i you know yeah you know
maybe it was a bit of a dallas bobby
ewing
moment but it was like guys but this is
what this movie is all about that's what
kingsman three is going to be about is
you know eggs and harry they're they're
i think they're just amazing to watch
these two together and
you know so we'd like to do one more
with with them
[Music]
this is about a it's a big set piece
where our heroes
there's a villain called rasputin a real
life feeling called rasputin who needs
to be
extinguished shall we say and uh so our
guys get together and
they know he's got a sweet tooth they
know he's got a uh a poncho should we
say for young men and women
and
uh they set the trap to try and kill him
now that's more like
time to dance
[Music]
on your graves
they get everything wrong and they
underestimate and what they thought
might be a rather simple mission turns
out to be um the dance of hell
[Music]
you're right
breathe
[Music]
that scene was a set because if we went
to any uh
russian stately palace home and smashed
it up like that i think would be big i i
yeah
yeah you'll be dedicating the film to me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
in that scene what was interesting we
did a lot of research into um
uh
cossack dancing right and because i've
always thought what are these guys why
are they sort of doing this with their
legs
horizontal you know
their ass
foot off the ground i was like who came
up with such a stupidly weird dance um
so i looked into it and i turned out
that these were it was a style of
fighting and kicking and and and then it
got banned so then it became a dance
and then we got the guys in that could
do it and it was just brilliant because
the stunt men couldn't do it and so the
stuntmen suddenly were like how the the
core strength of these guys
uh that were teaching them we had people
from russia and georgia and ballet
dancers
and then we just started taking some of
the ballet moves
the cossack dancing other traditional
russian folk dancing and we just
i got these stunt choreographers the
karate guys and we all came together and
then
came up
with with probably the most uh surreal
ballet you'll ever watch
[Music]
in the first kingsman when eggsy is told
by harry how kingsman was founded
in 1919 and the the folklore or the
foundation the kings were already put in
place so i had to go back
to
what
what harry hart had told eggsy
and then i read up about the history and
these characters were just
exploding off the page i mean i couldn't
ever come up with a character like
rasputin i mean he's a you know he's
just an extraordinary villain and then i
found out about the you know the
couldn't believe that the cousins were
you know this was like a family squabble
and all these events that really
happened like even when i read about the
zimmerman telegram to mexico asking the
mexicans to invade america to get texas
to come into the war and i'm like
yeah this is
this is just crazy that this happened so
i got very excited about the history
side of it and then even more excited
about the kingsman
see what i call the gray area where we
could slip the kingsman plot and stories
into it
now that's more like
time to dance
[Music]
on your graves
go and help your father
[Music]
i'm as a director i can only do things
i'm excited about because i'm not
excited about it why the hell would
anyone in the audience be excited so i
just thought
i i you know i've got to make a i want
to make a movie that is epic
entertaining engaging emotional and just
escapism
you're right
breathe
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not joking we shot this sequence
about three years ago so it feels like i
shot it
with the real rasputin back in
1917 or 18 where it was set that part um
um
it took weeks i know it took weeks it
was between the drama and the action i'd
say it's two and a half three weeks for
everything
um i think from the moment we got it
went into that set and got everybody out
it was about three weeks
time to dance
[Music]
on your graves
the knife and the in the boot there's
little things like that which are easter
eggs no one's really commented about
that's meant to be the blade coming out
of the you know the brogue and how
that's the first time we ever see it
even though it's done manually uh i
don't think i think it's gone over
everyone's head um so i do think there's
a lot of there are lots of little things
that on a second viewing
that there we've put a lot of easter
eggs
in there
and we've laid some for kingsman three
so we've put a few little things in this
that
i'm going to pay off in kingsman 3.
oh
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
you